[Music]
thank you very much indeed and welcome
everybody to this uh debate today moral
truths and moral tyrannies what are we
going to be talking about today um
well we're going to be talking about the
idea that absolute moral claims seem to
be making a uh a resurgence
along with demands for action in
response to that
yet at the same time
many proclaim the value and importance
of upholding
diverse cultural outlooks with sometimes
radically different moral codes
so to avoid this hypocrisy should we
give up the belief in a universal moral
code and see morality as nietzsche
argued
as the product of a monotheistic culture
which over the centuries has often led
to violence and even warfare
or should we reassert confidence in our
moral framework and deny alternative
accounts
is a universal moral code a guise for
the tyranny of western christian ethics
or is it the cornerstone of a fair and
just society in any culture and at any
time
so that's our debate for the day and
joining me i have three eminent thinkers
to
crunch through this fundamental question
of our times
tim williamson who's the wicked
professor of logic at the university of
oxford welcome tim who's made many many
important contributions to analytic
philosophy especially in the areas of
epistemology and logic we have maria
begramian who's the professor of
american philosophy
and
i think one of the world's leading
experts on moral and epistemological
relativism her work focusing on
contemporary epistemology relativism and
one of her recent projects when experts
disagree quote unquote perish the
thought received
three million euros of funding from the
european commission which she's
obviously spent partly on on her
fantastic wardrobe for this evening
and then last but not least we have
david friedman
very well known uh theorist uh known for
work on
anarcho-capitalism
and of course uh many of you may know
his book the machinery of freedom which
has become a kind of go-to text in that
uh subject area so so welcome to all
three of you in a second i'm gonna ask
our three distinguished panelists to as
it were set out their stall on this
question of uh
moral truths and moral tyrannies you
know the absolutes and the relatives
so tim if you're really i'm going to
come straight to you first if you don't
mind and um
i guess give us a bit of orientation in
terms of your thinking on this
subject which as you know has been set
up as a kind of uh dilemma of some kind
you know true absolute truths and
relative tyrannies and so on so
love to hear your thoughts on that tim
yeah well i think the first thing to say
is that the the usual
reasons for uh denying that uh morality
is absolute and universal are um
fallacious uh so the usual kind of
reasons have to do with
um disagreements on morality that are
irreconcilable in the sense that
it's clear that that neither side is
ever going to convince uh the other but
those disagreements do not show that
there's no truth of the matter uh
because of of all we have
irreconcilable disagreements uh for
example between
um evolutionary biologists and uh
creationists fundamentalists about the
theory of evolution but that doesn't
show that there's no uh truth of uh that
matter um
and in fact in in some cases it's not
just that there may be a truth um but
that we can know what it is although the
fact that a truth is non-relative does
not mean
that it's easy to know and of course uh
physics is an example uh which is full
of uh things that are very hard to know
but nevertheless there isn't a truth of
the matter another thing that's worth
bearing in mind
is that
when one says that a moral question has
a true answer one
isn't automatically claiming to know
what the answer is
although absolutism about morality is
sometimes uh portrayed as um and sort of
arrogant for you i think it's actually
the the humbling uh view because
uh it implies that some of our moral
beliefs may be just false
whereas by contrast as a relativist view
it lets us off the hook by uh insisting
that our moral beliefs are fine relative
to our own perspective i mean that
there's that we can't be uh
falling short of some absolute uh
standard um
but i don't i don't want to
push uh
too much skepticism about um knowledge
of uh moral truths because i think that
i mean there are some moral truths which
uh it's pretty plausible are known in
most uh societies and an example of that
would be that
torturing children for fun is
a pretty widely um
known truth uh amongst in human
societies i think another point that
needs to be remembered is that the
absoluteness of morality does not imply
that it morality consists of simple
rules um and the i mean the absolute
rightness or wrongness of an action may
depend in very complex ways on the
circumstances in which the action is
done and by the way that's a completely
different kind of dependence from its
dependence on the circumstances of the
person
judging the action and because those are
not what's relevant it's the
circumstances of the action itself and
so uh an example of of that would be
that that might be let's say that
euthanasia is absolutely right in some
circumstances and uh absolutely uh wrong
in in others so it may be that
um
some very complex uh morality is in fact
absolutely true but doesn't consist of
simple moral rules
thanks
that's uh great tim thank you very much
i mean you may be able to see my piano
in the background and that's certainly
an instrument i used to torture my
children with for fun like that um
okay very very struck by also your point
about um
absolute truths not necessarily being
easy to know so maybe we'll come back to
that one
um thank you very much tim so maria can
i can i move on to you and just hear
your kind of opening thoughts on this
subject uh i
my thinking about
ethics morality and relativism and
absolutism starts from the point that
tim actually rejected namely the
prevalence and significance of this
on ethical issues i think
disagreement about ethics is quite
different from disagreement between
scientists and
religious fundamentalists on evolution
because in those cases there are
methodologies for establishing what is
scientifically correct and incorrect and
also there are there are the
presuppositions that they uh religious
fundamentalists bring to the topic of
their disagreement while in ethics even
when we have well-informed equally uh
educated
people coming from similar background we
can still have this agreement and these
are the cases of intractable or deep
disagreements that don't apply to the
same extent in the natural sciences so
how do we deal with these deep
disagreements there are a few options
one is to go relativist and to say they
are all right all these positions are
correct each according to their cultural
context or background that's an easy
option it resolves or dissolves the
disagreement but i don't find it
satisfactory and we can discuss that
later on second option is just to go
skeptical and say oh there's no such
truth in ethics it's all subjective
um
but also for various reasons it's not
very satisfactory third option is what
tim suggested that
we say yeah there are true genetics they
are difficult to find
but we have made progress in ethics look
i mean look at aristotle or count on
their views of
women or slavery or
race and compared to what we believe now
these are
very clear cases of moral progress so
there is such a thing as truth in the
morality and we are moving towards that
uh so i do agree to that extent with tim
but i don't think we can be absolutist
about ethics and here comes my own spill
on the issue i'm not a relatively sorry
realist i'm a pluralist about ethics uh
so uh
what does it mean to be a pluralist
about ethics uh means to say that there
could be more than one right answer to
the question to the ethical question how
should we live or should we conduct
ourselves or should we treat each other
uh we can rule out the wrong answers and
yes we do rule out the answer that it's
right
torture children but there are many
right answers on how we should treat our
children uh and and the pluralist
affirms that sort of plurality of truths
rather than absolutely true
thank you very much for that maria and
when we get into our first um
theme i may come back to you to kick off
because i find very interesting this
idea of um
ethics being different from science
presumably because of an absence of
empirical
data to ground it in the same way so
when we start talking about what is
ethics actually grounded in maybe i can
come back to you on that one and very
interesting to the idea that there can
be more than one
right answer that right answers can
compete in some way or or um or coexist
in some way thank you very much maria
and i will move on now then to to you
david if that's okay where she just tell
us where you're coming from on your uh
all right also
i'm a moral realist okay my position as
far as i can tell so far must be very
similar to tim's
although we did not conspire in advance
that my view is that there are true
moral statements that there's a moral
reality out there in the same sense
there's a physical reality out there and
that we perceive the physical reality
with our senses we perceive the moral
reality with what you might think of as
a moral sense what people will sometimes
call moral intuition
that we test both of those by
consistency
that we could it could be that my
perception of physical reality is wrong
i could be a brain and a vatican all the
illusions but the best test i can make
is to make sure that my different
sources of information on physical
reality are consistent i don't see a
lion on the dining room table when i
reach out i don't touch it it doesn't
scratch me i don't smell it other people
see other people seeing the lion
if i meet someone who claims there's a
lion on the table and is serious i
conclude he's insane that he's not
actually perceiving reality i think if
you look at moral reality not in terms
of high level statements such as what
rights do we have but in terms of actual
perception in this fully described
situation did this person act correctly
was that good or bad which gets back to
tim's example of torturing children
that i think you get a very large level
of agreement across people and across
culture and that a lot of what looks
like disagreement about morality
is either disagreement about physical
reality
facts that are relevant to moral reality
that king james believed it was right to
burn witches not because his moral
beliefs were different but because he
believed in witchcraft and we don't
uh or else there are disagreements not
about the underlying facts about the
theories built on top of them so that
for
about two thousand years uh educated
people believed that the earth was at
the center of the universe surrounded by
crystal spheres the ptolemaic view
containing the planets and the moon and
the sun
but those people saw the same things
they saw the sun the same way we do they
saw objects the same way we do they just
constructed a different high level
picture of the whole pattern and in the
same sense i think that moral
disagreements very largely uh maybe
entirely i'm not sure come down to
people constructing different high-level
structures on the basis of their
perception of both moral and physical
reality if you really get into political
arguments you find that the people very
rarely agree about the physical facts uh
quite aside from the moral facts so that
would be my position which is what
sometimes described as moral realism
very i find the idea of your opening
phrase moral reality sort of exists
almost in the same way as physical
reality fascinating
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas